we've been reporting a lot about the
rising costs of grass gas and groceries
and while those have been going up
stocks and cryptocurrencies have been
going way down yeah to help break it all
down for us we're joined by author leia
helper and thanks for joining us talk
about bitcoin first it's been branded as
the hedge against inflation at least
that's the way it was initially marketed
to people the new gold uh but
inflation's you know near 30 40-year
highs and bitcoins tanking what's going
on
well thanks for having me on it's a
great question and because ultimately
people do look at bitcoin as that hedge
against inflation but i think it's
really important to zoom out and look at
the march 2020 crash bitcoin is up
nearly four i think over 400 since the
march 2020 cash crash so ultimately it
is still that hedge against inflation
like you said 40 year highs if people
had invested in that point they would be
in a much better position right now we
also have to consider the fact that you
know you say it's tanking and it's
crashing but it's only crashing to the
highs of the previous bull market
nothing goes up forever market cycles do
go in cycles and of course things do
have to cool um to cool off people right
now don't have the surplus cash to put
into um alternative asset classes or
investing in general simply because of
the cost of living crisis because
everything is so much more expensive
right now but
long term it is important to zoom out
and leia a lot of people are struggling
to pay for gas or groceries should they
be thinking about investing and why
it really depends what your investment
strategy is and how much money um and
how much surplus cash you have i can't
give you any financial advice but i do
think that bitcoin is that hedge against
inflation long term um we've already
seen like i said up 400
uh since that march 2020 crash if you do
have um surplus cash then you should be
looking to investing and you should be
looking to uh find a form of hedge
against inflation whether it's gold
whether it's bitcoin whatever you're
most comfortable with because i don't
think uh it looks like inflation is
going to be uh calming down anytime soon
leah the other issue with bitcoin
initially it was sold as an item that
would be uh limited in supply a finite
number of these uh coins could be made
and that also sounded really appealing
to a lot of investors but a lot of
people including myself didn't realize
that you could make an endless number of
different coins and has that diluted um
bitcoin's value i wonder
not really um you have bitcoin and then
you have many other different
cryptocurrencies and some
cryptocurrencies like dogecoin for
example have an unlimited supply but
that's completely separate and
completely different to bitcoin bitcoin
will only ever be there will only ever
be 21 million bitcoin no more can ever
be created and that's actually
implemented in the math and the code and
that mapping code is set in stone and it
cannot be changed so whatever the other
cryptocurrencies are doing is irrelevant
um it doesn't affect bitcoin all it does
unfortunately is distract people um you
know people want to make a lot of money
pretty quickly and so they might look to
something like dogecoin and say oh wow
this is pretty cheap maybe you know i
can make the same kind of games but
unfortunately that distracts them it
moves them away from what we would
regard as sound money something with a
limited supply like bitcoin so no it
doesn't affect bitcoin's value it just
distracts people unfortunately and there
are several reports that black americans
have been impacted the hardest by this
price crash is that true and why is that
i'm afraid i can't speak uh
intelligently as to why black people
might be more affected by the crash as
opposed to white people or asian people
and uh leia talk about um we talked
about those other coins but a lot of
other companies too that are freezing
accounts now and that raises a lot of
concern for people they you know they
kind of blame all the crypto market when
it's maybe some of these you know
outside or these smaller coins how does
that affect confidence
yeah unfortunately it really does um
instill a lot of unfair uncertainty and
doubt but that's simply because they are
using centralized exchanges so it's a
bit like leaving your money with the
bank which kind of goes against the
ethos of bitcoin in the first place um
and so yes a lot of these companies and
because of the market volatility right
now and there's a lot of selling
pressure are approaching their
liquidation price and they're
withholding uh withdrawals this is
concerning but it doesn't actually
matter because the idea here when it
comes to bitcoin is that you take um you
you take self custody of the asset this
means not leaving it in the custody of a
third party you can buy on an exchange
but then you want to withdraw it take
self-custody and hold it in a
non-custodial manner which literally
means there's no third party it's just
you and your assets you're fully
sovereign nobody can freeze your funds
nobody can confiscate them um it doesn't
matter what happens with the market it
doesn't matter how much selling pressure
there is because ultimately you hold
that money and that's the education part
which i think is so important and
because like you mentioned yes it does
um make people feel very concerned about
bitcoin concerned about the market but
again this is centralized uh exchanges
and also we see this with banks globally
we see this in lebanon we've seen it in
canada where people's funds are frozen
where money is confiscated and so the
best thing to do is to hold it in a
non-custodial way no third party just
you and your bitcoin all right so
informative thank you so much leila leia
excuse me for joining us this morning we
appreciate you